bertrand alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé
ces derniers jours parce qu'on l'a vue
mardi la reine avait pourtant reçu la
nouvelle première ministre anglais zaoui
sa prise de fonction la voilà c'est ça
la dernière absolument oui c'est sa
dernière apparition efforts alertés par
la tâche bleue que l'on voit sur sa main
ont saisi ce bizarre on n'avait pas vu
encore sa tâche là au préalable mais moi
je vous avoue que la trouve pas mourante
manon pour une photo d'il ya deux jours
moi je la trouve pas me rends du tout je
me dis 'mon d'un coup moi mon livre du
sort dans deux mois au couple quoi voilà
banon tout compte fait il semblerait que
le lendemain avec le mercredi elle est
contracté une avc accident vasculaire
cérébral se serait apparemment ce qui
figurait sur l'homme sur le certificat
de décès qui a été signé donc là
officiellement par son médecin qui est
le docteur robertson qui est le médecin
attitré qu'elle a lorsqu'elle séjourne
sommes en écosse savent ça fait partie
aussi des fameuses étape du london
bridge exact est ce que sa famille était
déjà là où ils ont dû rapatrier tous
alors à césar non pas dans si on regarde
les cas pitching hâtivement à 16 heures
tout le monde n'était pas encore harry
par exemple qui est arrivé sur le tard
n'était pas présent asesor sûr et
certain charles camilla william était à
son chevet ils sont arrivés en tout
début d'après midi il faudrait voir si
vraiment ces deux autres fils ap un trou
edwards
était vraiment et son épouse bref
étaient présents parce qu'ils sont
arrivés par voie diplomatique
est-ce qu'il était déjà 16 or je ne sais
plus frais que l'on vérifié alors qu'est
ce qui va se passer dans l'est dans les
prochains jours parce que on a parlé du
jubilé les 70 ans de règne donc la reine
elizabeth il ne rien elle a participé à
ce jubilé vous nous disait toujours
après le jubilé
j'ai peur qu'elles attendent le jubilé
pour dorian partir ben oui absolument
j'ai utilisé que c'est une commode avec
des tiroirs et elle décidera elle-même
le moment où elle le refermera elle a
travaillé jusque mardi donc mission
accomplie jusqu'au bout dans le fond
elle a toujours eu le devoir cheville et
au corps c'est quelque chose qui me qui
me fascine aussi qu'est ce qui va se
passer c'est très simple ce jour ci a
été décrété un peu le dit et les
funérailles auront lieu au deed puisse
disent donc maintenant dans dix jours
alors on se pose une question parce que
dans dix jours ça tombe à dimanche est
ce que vraiment ils vont vraiment
célébrer les funérailles le dimanche on
n'est pas encore certain à ce que ce
serait pas peut se poser au samedi ou
peut-être au lundi en tout cas on arrive
dans une période de deuil incroyable
plus de cinéma plus de théâtre tout cela
va nous faire même séance au parlement
l'a tous fait fermer le tout est
absolument ferme célébrités tout ça ça
reste ouvert ce ne sera vraiment que le
jour des funérailles et et ce jour est
ce que c est ce qu'il va devenir ferrier
là bas oui alors le jour des funérailles
est vraiment fériés et non mais ça va
perdurer ou ce sera que pour cette année
donc férié en angleterre le jour des
très bons pneus est-ce que ça va
perdurer après ou pas des anneaux non
saison non non non dans cinq ans après
en revanche la cour tous les membres de
la cour vont prendre un deuil qui lui va
durer pendant trois mois